johnny depp and everybody heard it will
be interesting to see what kind of
fallout they have to deal with from this
trial as day 16 delivered more
bombshells
he started to pass out a lot he was on
drug binge no eating little to no sleep
and he would just use cocaine and drink
all day long nothing i did made him stop
hitting me
nothing amber described pics she took of
her then boyfriend slumped over
testifying that johnny's substance abuse
fueled jealous rages which got worse
when talk turned to a prenup johnny said
he would tear it up
only way out of this is death
he was
mad at me for taking the job with james
franco he
hated
hated
james franco was accusing me of having
affairs
tell me did he slip a tongue
depp appeared to disagree at times while
she spoke even wincing while the jury
heard audio amber recorded of him after
she claims he drunkenly assaulted her
aboard a jet
he called me a [ __ ]
and he slaps my face
it just kicked me
in the back
amber broke down for her second day on
the stand
i've never been
so scared of my life
it was black i couldn't see him earlier
she claimed his drug use even led to
sexual assault which he denies
he's telling me we're doing we're gonna
we're gonna conduct a cavity search you
know i didn't know what to do i just
didn't
i just stood there
well he did that i was
so torn i was so in love with this
person but he was also this other thing
and the other thing was
[Music]
awful you